hey what's up welcome to our one of day
one waiting for all our actors to get
here to put them in a costume and then
we'll actually start working pretty good
to be interesting that mix of funny and
cool like so you can pull it off either
welcome to behind the scenes for how to
reach this is a fun little skit piece we
put together here shot with some our
friends from EMC the stunt group as well
as our friend Kevin Brewer who played
the material I have a name for column
skips McGee the tactical instructor so
for those of you guys to follow us on
Instagram probably saw we were shooting
this video back in August last year and
may have wondered why it took so long to
come out well we made a video about
killing terrorists and then in the real
world terrorists actually attacked Paris
France it's not to be in pretty poor
taste and kind of disrespectful to
release this video so close to those
terrorist attacks so I decided to put on
the shelf give it some time and now some
time is passed for everything actually
put it back out there for people to
enjoy there's a bunch of people in the
world and they kill people for no reason
yeah so Nico came up with the original
concept for this video he thought hey
you know what's funny
top 10 videos you know it's even more
funny military tutorial training videos
maybe four or five years ago back when
Freddy was living with us crazy showed
us these series of videos called part of
the tactical carbine and they were kind
of over the top put in a really
hilarious and great way basically
they're led by this guy named Chris
Costa it's just like testosterone
yelling here's how you handle guns be
ready for any situations super extreme
yeah
and we thought be really find a can deal
with a parody of that one action the
narrator is a friend of ours named Kevin
Brooke he's been around the YouTube
world for a while and he's got a great
personality for this so we gave him a
call asked him if he wanted to do it and
he was really excited about it he came
on in he gave a great performance oh we
talked about it for a little while I did
a couple of different voices we were
gonna go a little bit rougher you know
like
military man like this but at the end of
the day we felt the bravado of Brock
Samson from Venture Brothers combined
from limited Billy Mays yeah kind of two
great days to go great together you know
like caramel and Chuck yeah like peanut
butter and accents
ruin almost every take by having this
crack up halfway through it I filmed a
twitch giggling good job Kevin
the next people we worked with was the
EMC monkeys who are kind of our go-to
for sweet action and stunt effects then
we called out to a couple of our friends
Amy Johnson who's an awesome stunt woman
actress in the area Richard Ryan of full
mag and rated-r are who you might know
from his own endeavors on YouTube Cote
Galloway who's always fallen to work
with I always brings the energy Joseph
Seaton he's a former Army Ranger Joseph
actually came all the way out from Texas
to be in this video
huh he's one of the challenges that we
had making on this piece is we had to
spend like two days shooting all the
breaching and you know it's it's action
you have like five guys reaching into a
room and then you have a whole bunch of
guys in the room and you're doing it 10
times Hey
ha very nice so you choreographic
actually 10 mini action scenes so we
built a fake wall we bought 25 doors
busted them replace the door bust it
replace the door I know how strong doors
on out the answer is not very your ever
in your house and you get out really
fast just go right through that door the
challenging thing is there's a whole
narration that goes on top of all this
so you're not just shooting an action
scene particularly shooting illustration
or a recreation that's then going to go
over a narration all the structures
changing after you shot all the
illustrations are going to use so you're
sitting there with this just pile of
footage with you know you have like an
hour of this guy narrating the stuff and
going through all these different
breaches and then you have all these
reaches and it's like put it all
together but Kevin made that easy Kevin
made it really easy to be funny with
this piece this games comedy go did you
guys see that he just had his hand down
my pants what were you doing just seeing
how what you got which working my secret
see what I'm working with yeah you see
that desert eagle down there yep yeah so
aperture gave us some really cool lights
for this video really mobile really easy
to use really easy to set up there's our
first time using it it's pretty cool so
there's so many LEDs on these things I
don't know they packed them all in you
know what the best thing about them is
we set them up and we could just turn
them on and off with a remote boom so
you can sit there when the shots time
die and all the lights turn off and save
batteries and it's like alright lights
up Boop and you turn them all back on
sounds kind of cool we haven't really
ever been able to do that before anyway
that's it for this video we hope you
guys really enjoyed this and we're
really happy to be able to put this out
finally for the world to see thank you
for watching if you have any questions
leave them in the comments below we also
have a corridor digital Instagram
officially so that's Instagram at
corridor digital check it out
whoa